[Musique]
hier soir encore ils étaient environ 200
au jardin des tuileries
200 jeunes réunis pour faire la fête
danser chanter jusqu'à l'intervention de
la police vers 1h30 du matin des fêtes
géantes un peu partout en france un
match de rugby samedi qui ne respectent
pas les consignes sanitaires et demain
soir le premier match des bleus face à
l'allemagne faut-il abrogé avec quinze
jours d'avancé le couvre feu comme le
réclament certains élus 10h changerait
quoi mais c'est bien qu'il faut
justement garder un certain nombre de
règles parce que si on avait suivi cette
logique
ça veut dire qu'on aurait assoupli un
certain nombre de fois j'en aurais fait
du stop and go on aurait souhaité qu'ils
en auraient recours à l'effet du réseau
et le masque pour nous vraiment
l'abandonner à l'extérieur le 1er
juillet la pression monte pour accélérer
le retour à la vie normale et donc si
tout se passe bien on lèvera encore un
certain nombre de contraintes
le 30 juin si les conditions le
permettent donc plus de masques en
extérieur à partir du 30 juin
mais quelques minutes après cette
interview est comme un désaveu le
ministère de la santé fait parvenir ce
communiqué à la fp aucune décision n'a
encore été prise concernant le port du
masque en extérieur dans les prochaines
semaines qui reste donc la règle
je pense qu'on doit suspendre libyen
suspendre de manière temporaire
l'immigration jusqu'à ce que une partie
et ce n'est qu'une partie de la
population d'origine immigrée
ce soit assimilé c'est-à-dire et
intégrer les lois de la république
suspendre en cerdan alors suspens
pendant plusieurs années
le vent mauvais qui souffle dans notre
pays un vent mauvais l'autorité des plus
respectés à aucun moment il n'est pas
possible il n'est pas pensable qu'un
président de la république soit giflé
comme c'était le cas d'emmanuel
maquereau ou là quelques jours mais si
vous voulez qu'il y ait le respect de
l'autorité
il faut aussi qu'il y ait du respect
entre les uns et des autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on doit évidemment on appeler à la
raison c'est à chaque fois le fait
d'individus isolés c'est dommage parce
qu'ils arrivent à quelques jours de
capter l'attention par des actions
violentes et c'est malheureusement le
lot de notre société moderne
si c'est un climat que créer ces
personnes-là jeune homme quitte à
l'origine de cette action a d'ailleurs
dit je précise à nouveau que il ne
visait pas spécifiquement génération
donc nous n'y croyez pas non pas du tout
il a une télé web télé enfin vous savez
way qui n'invite que des gens d'extrême
droite
d'accord donc non je peux vous dire
qu'il visait jean luc mélenchon et moi
même celui qui fait le kéké pour
reprendre son expression c'est un député
françois ruffin qu'on ne voit jamais à
l'assemblée nationale si ce n'est pour
faire un esclandre pour faire une vidéo
sur youtube et pour dire voilà je vous
ai défendu ce pas comme ça qu'on défend
les gens c'est pas en faisant semblant
d'être député pour mieux vendre son
journal ou mieux faire des films à des
genres d'ile-de-france ici ce soir
est ce que vous avez envie d'île de
france
est ce que vous avez prévu de voter pour
laurent sa master
ah bon j'ai l'impression que la réponse
et nous sommes au début de jour nouveau
difficile et ce n'est pas un mot exagéré
nous allons travailler tous ensemble
revenez immédiatement le pays en
fonctionnement normal après une longue
période de paralysie et de querelles
naftali bennet devient premier ministre
après douze ans benyamin nétanyahou se
retrouvent donc écarté du pouvoir mais
annonce rester en politique afin de
faire tomber le nouveau gouvernement
bah je me battrai avec vous chaque jour
contre ce gouvernement ignoble et
dangereux afin de le renverser mais
grâce à dieu ait créé cela arrivera bien
plus vite que ce que vous pensez
j'entame prochain
début aujourd'hui du procès de l'ex
dirigeante birmane aung san suu çi
renversé par un coup d'état militaire
elle a été inculpé pour corruption
des accusations absurdes selon ses
avocats qui va tomber